[Music]
and plot twist mute all that we stole
Beach cement if I come for food bomb hey
yay a woman is suing for 1 million after
her boyfriend buntao hurt during sex I
would wait what is she so who is she
suing she's suing her boyfriend after he
bugged out her while he was having sex
with someone else I don't even know it
started the law what's the law behind
this oh it's illegal to do that my
emotional stress I'm traumatized by you
it's not in his pocket is he [ __ ]
through yeah what the hell I mean maybe
he like stepped on her before or like
maybe like Siri her I'll call whoever
you know I mean I don't know call me
daddy
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] up like honestly I
believe in the universe and you're gonna
find out what you have to find out and
look at this girl found out what she
needs to find out hurry you can sue for
that [ __ ] now I wouldn't know the law I
wish you would let you see free what
country this happened in Nashville go
USA go okay so this is what happened
this woman she was dating her boyfriend
for four years so he ends up but dialing
her and this phone call lasted for one
hour and 28 minutes she stayed on the
phone and listen to him having sex book
yeah I recorded it wasn't just him just
having sex good sex off gay sex another
man oh my god that's kind of hot [ __ ]
that's nice that's kind of hot I get two
guys now you know I don't think they
want
I want to watch I don't want to be in it
you want me to see me [ __ ] another dude
or me get [ __ ] you just put that image
in my head ah yeah really hot guy by
himself in that nothing you're not hot
at all you just completely dissed the
[ __ ] out of them what in the [ __ ] are
you doing right now general make a
comment about her looks right now part
two I think about you hot guys gay guys
are known to stereotypically really
groom and take care of themselves
this guy's a manly man he's a brute okay
that's why I love him
I shave all my hairs off no no you don't
but that's what I picture some silk yes
moisturize face like a Beijing silk
right here I was offended for it and
that's why it's like I don't want to see
that dumb about two hot guys Becky no
cuz he's not getting relationship poles
alright he's a manly man
fine what Bellamy and Davey wavey oh my
god Tom started sweaty is only just
because I don't you just do with them
and I got scared
don't you [ __ ] game so the reason why
she's suing is because after that phone
call she got herself tested and she
found out that she has an incurable STD
oh yeah okay that changes everything
which STD they don't mention what I'm
sure sorry it was a HSV - to which is
general herpes
oh my she didn't know this dude was gay
right she didn't know
yeah that's at least she's not gonna die
from it yeah I mean but her [ __ ] life
is ruined
yeah dude what she's pregnant she can
have her kid for like vaginal birth like
there's hell yes explain it to all of
her partners now she has to take
medication for the rest of her life
suka Alba has it all right so is this
packed how do you do that
have you seen it I think Jessica Alba
has herpes you can't see I think Britney
Spears has every straight flame and
everybody I think Jennifer Lawrence has
dude yeah Jessica Alba that's [ __ ] up
though that is so much she does have it
Emily black hasn't do it you can't come
back [ __ ] strong and confident [ __ ]
did I got mad nervous though but she
does have it as she has two beautiful
gym houses yeah but she's nothing you
can't have I know but it kind of sucks
when we say like her life is ruined
because there are a lot of people with
that and I only know this because my
friend is a doctor and he's Derek Jeter
has there's a lot of people that okay
I'm sorry the reason why I said it that
way is just saying her life is
inconvenience not because of a lie
inconvenience yeah yes and it's just
[ __ ] up to have a partner who prefers
something and they're just with you for
something out yeah you know and I mean
like don't have Paris Hilton got it
Robbie Sears the celebs I just feel like
there are fuckathon all the time and
they've been within the same circle
maybe well I mean you just have so many
people around you just [ __ ] all day
you guys are like these beers they found
her buying herpes medicine so it doesn't
really compromise I don't know man it's
just the second before - it's the same
thing it's literally the same thing but
just in two different areas
oh if I go with stereotypes right like
females at that level
want to [ __ ] dudes at that level right
mm-hmm but dude at that level [ __ ]
anything about anything so they're gonna
have everything and then the females are
gonna get I don't know a truth is
Lissa's yeah I think Jessica Alba was
open about it though about it so she was
open about her she talked about it but
the rest is entirety they say about brie
Larson I heard she had to do
at Marvel but I'd rather show them dude
that took that story yeah
so now she's suing for a million dollars
for battery infliction of emotional
distress both intentional and neglect
negligence and fraud I don't know she
lied to her yeah and then so she tried
talking to him about it he was just like
nope and then even no we're not talking
even her I said it nah
so he's so homophobic against himself
like he rather just like [ __ ] up
everyone's health and have this woman in
a relationship too so he seems like
hetero yeah for years
Oh like get married would like the
opposite sex have kids and then they
come out when they're like older you
know like just own up to your truth
you're in the u.s. like it's not that
serious but it's in Nashville right yeah
Tennessee also maybe I have a friend who
kind of went that well their day was
seven years and their got to get a house
together and then she just out of
nowhere like I was like place yeah I
can't do it I'll break it up and then
she came out no no she said I can't do
this it's too much
she's like her excuse was I'm moving on
too fast 77 years that is really a few
months later like speedlights few months
like she just basically said like she's
going through a quarter life crisis few
months later she gets with a girl she
was she was in the closet the point yeah
yeah and I was just like man I can't
imagine how that feels to go seven years
with this girl and then all of a sudden
find out she doesn't like Davis yeah if
you from friends I know your roster
fiction I can't imagine mentally like
how that yeah you know like all that sex
all that time was like fake like you got
a question I think sexuality is like a
big spectrum and people can still enjoy
a certain sex and be attracted and
emotionally attached to the other you
know like sexuality doesn't necessarily
mean you only enjoy one thing and some
people are open like that that they can
enjoy both you know it just it's [ __ ]
up for somebody to keep it a secret you
know like if you are it within the
spectrum or you have some sort of
openness to both like you should
definitely be open with your partner and
say hey
yeah this is what I'm attracted to and
if you want to stay in a relationship
with me while I figure it out then
that's awesome and if not then you know
it's fine like somebody else will want
to be in a relationship with me it's
selfish for you to keep that information
to yourself I've never seen a dude that
I feel like I could enjoy you [ __ ]
straight as [ __ ] yeah I think I saw
30-some odd years of hasn't happened yet
I figure pretty good you never know you
might wake up one day and be like God
that geo pussy's played out yeah
probably I can see that happening I mean
that I mean that guy just like Halloween
he goes well you develop like lactose
intolerant when you're like thirty or
some [ __ ] I think there's so much we
don't know about the brain and like
human connection and human-like
interaction how can we ever know you
know what I mean is such a weird gray
area too because if somebody says like
oh you maybe you don't know yet because
it also kind of gives the argument to
other people who say that homosexuality
is a choice it kind of gives them that
little little little thing to say that
oh so you're saying that I could you
know I mean so it's like a weird thing
so it's like oh we gotta be careful I'm
definitely not saying you could choose
but I'm just saying thing buddy maybe
it's just open Riaan occasionally come
definitely communicate if you have some
sort of feelings about it cuz that's
[ __ ] up his foot I know he was
straight-up cheating on her and gave her
in it I don't know you could win money
from that well because of the fact that
he really like biological dad mister I
think I think this could be for a
straight couple as well like if he would
have been cheating with the girl you
know what I mean it still would have
been the same outside and gave her
something that cuz if somebody gave I
didn't know if somebody gave me like an
STD I could be like you can't if they
knew about it okay yeah so r.kelly he
was charged because he gave this 19 year
old she was an underage but he gave her
per piece and she came out and that was
one of the cases that they were trying
to take him to jail for because he knew
he had herpes and she didn't know until
obviously after she got it
I [ __ ] hate argue me too me too no
not not in here you know
ronk ronk stop you know
20 last night last night we saw the
movie showed them and in that movie the
old one
it's the old one no no the new one oh
and in that movie the kids telling him
like you in order for you to fly like
you have to believe that you can fly and
he just kept saying I believe I can fly
I believe I could like and I feel like
they had a scene in Oh singing that song
they probably cut it out oh you just
kept saying like I believe I can fly I
believe it you know what I forgot about
Kevin Spacey oh yeah I was watching baby
driver it's not yeah and I completely
forgot about all that stuff but I think
I'm just prone to separating drama from
the art so I never I don't even think
the first time I heard about that's the
drama for me if it's huge drama I
cancelled yeah if it's like I can't rape
yeah I mean yeah we can't Spacey now
sherry yeah I can't separate that are
you okay with the MJ stuff then even
though it's not proven well because it's
not proven I know but there's a lot of
drama around it though well because it's
not proven I'm it's not until it's
proven and there's facts then I'm like
what would you need to be like okay it's
hot wait is hard now all you need for
you to be like okay this really have a
video of him doing it yeah oh damn
that's like a lot of em today by our
Kelly evidence some guy so I'm sort of
like hard concrete and Evans know this
crazy anymore either because they have
those deep yourself lady and then you
can manipulate your voice to say
whatever the [ __ ] you want it to say
people said that his voice his his
interview voice is not even real like
behind the scenes he has a normal voice
but when he talks for somebody out in
the public he's it's crazy
maybe because he cuz he grew up in there
limelight since he was five years old
he's like stays of that kid in the
limelight I never touched those children
hmm
[Music]
[Music]